foreign
the fact that so few people are taking
the boosters yeah tells us that lots of
people have updated something in their
model whether they've become agnostic
about the whole thing and they're in
their minds procrastinating and you know
they just haven't gotten it yet or
whatever they're doing something is
protecting them from getting further
doses even though they haven't stated
you know what I used to think X and now
I don't because and that's the thing
we're waiting for right like it's it's
those sorts of
admission makes it sound too onerous
right but
honesty be honest with yourself and then
share that Honesty at least with the
people whom you shamed and debilitated
at least share your your newfound
honesty with those uh
for whom you're being wrong
had a direct negative effect and you you
know I you won't know until you do it if
it's not something that you're used to
doing you won't know until you do it but
you will feel so much better
right it's not easy to say hey I really
screwed this up I thought I had it right
but it's really not easy to say but you
will just viscerally feel a huge weight
off your shoulders in doing it and by
and large
you know
the game theory says it's all about the
future always it can never be about
anything else and so the point is when
you say to somebody even somebody who
even if you've been terrible to somebody
because you were absolutely sure that
they had fallen down the conspiracy
theory Rabbit Hole whatever that means
right
you may have been terrible to somebody
and if you say look
I screwed it up here's how but I
understand that I did I feel bad about
it I won't do it again right if you say
that to somebody it is not in their
interest to say well I don't accept your
apology you know there's nothing you can
do to mend this in general especially if
you have a relationship that has content
that goes beyond whatever took place
over covid people will forgive you
people will be decent to you and you
will just simply not have to live with
that fear of you know what happens if it
emerges
well so the idea of people will be
decent to you though those of us who
have been you know vilified and you know
we have been quite lucky
we haven't lost
people or jobs or
you've been told to stand outside on
Christmas and and such as many people
have
uh
those of us on that side of the things
are not the ones who aren't being decent
right
um but one thing that I hear and what
you're saying that I that I hope is true
but I'm not sure it is
the kind of heartfelt I looked inside of
myself I'm seeing the New Evidence
and I I behaved badly and I was wrong
that hopefully can help rebuild trust
but one of the things that has frayed
and decayed and in some cases it's
irreparable is trust between people
and so again
um from conversations I had this last
week
what I'm hearing from people
who have not been apologized to who have
lost relationships who have lost
livelihoods all of this
but one thing I'm hearing from them is
I don't know
I don't know if I want the relationships
back
because I won't ever trust them again
and it's not about
it's not about like I won't trust them
because they hurt me but specifically
the thing that was said I heard this on
more than one occasion was
I gave them what I knew about what the
evidence was and they still vaccinated
their children
I don't trust them I will never trust
them with my children again
and like what
what do you do
well I don't know what you do no
I'm afraid we all do and it's built in
the the real thing hinges on the
distinction between a pro forma or
hedging apology and a real one
and the reason that it hinges on that is
not some touchy-feely thing
a real apology in which the person has
done the accounting of their own
wrongdoing is the insurance that makes
them safe to deal with going forward
perfectly safe No but none of us are
perfectly safe
so what there's a there's a there's a
principle right at the point that a
company
has had a major Scandal what was it I'm
not going to mention the brand because
I'm not 100 certain of it I've forgotten
but there was a tire company that had
covered up the fact that there were
blowouts that had killed a number of
people right yep
um the point is in the aftermath of that
scandal
there's actually a degree of safety in
buying those tires because of all
companies that company cannot afford to
have the pattern continue and so you
would expect extra vigilance in fact you
would expect that that company might be
willing to take a loss on each tire in
order to ensure that it was clear that
this pattern had gone away the extra
scrutiny from the public because of past
wrongs will will make for extra
vigilance on the part of the company
right so what I would say is and in my
personal policy which I have I have said
before is
um
a complete accounting of what you did
wrong if it really is complete is
sufficient now there are people here who
I believe committed knowing wrongs who
can't apologize and never will because
to do so would be effectively to confess
to crimes I I think you're talking a
different level though this is this is
funny though because you know having
just spent time with that transcript
from almost 10 months ago I feel like
we're having that conversation again at
some level
and um
the the issue
is not so much
did they see that it like even someone
who says oh wow oh I see now I shouldn't
have had my children vaccinated with
these vaccines with these ones
uh I won't do that again
even that
leaves open the reality
like it doesn't change the reality of
that
you were the sort of person and you know
the one I was talking this one
particular conversation she invoked my
my mama Bear's piece and substance she
said
she said to me
you
my once dear friend are the sort of
person
who gave up being a mama bear
and trusted someone who'd already lied
to you and let them have your children
I can't trust you with my children ever
again if you do that I don't care what
kind of apology you make I don't care if
you know that you were wrong the fact is
there's something in your head there's
something in their head that allowed you
to sacrifice your children
and no apologies changes that look I I
get it
on the other hand a full apology would
involve the recognition which is very
hard to reach that you put your own
children in danger because you trusted
something that you knew you should have
known better than to trust right so the
point is if somebody said that to you
like I can't believe that I allowed my
children
to be vaccinated in this way when you
know I was being told hey even if these
vaccines work the risk goes up the
younger you are and the risk of covid is
spectacularly low right right if
somebody says hey I now get that that
message was available to me at the time
and I allowed myself to be blinded and
it had a it placed it my kids in danger
right if somebody said that then the
point is How likely is it that somebody
who has had to wrestle with the terrible
knowledge that they put their own
children in danger uh is going to
blindly do that again and if they did
start to blindly do that again and you
said Hey do you remember that time
that you took this I but I I feel like
you often say to me no their minds
aren't like that right and I think you
know the 15 years that we spent really
teaching college students like actually
really getting to know 25 50 75 students
really well over the course of a quarter
or two or a full Academic Year or more
who gave us both the sense of like
almost everyone's reachable almost
everyone's alive in there and um has is
is waiting if they haven't already
discovered it
um to be sparked into creativity and
productivity and invention and
discovering exploration and so many
interesting things it was the very rare
student even at this really not Elite
College who wasn't couldn't couldn't be
inspired into doing some interesting
work and yet and yet we see it's like
the population level where we don't you
know we don't know any of these people
we don't have access to them and their
individual Minds on you know a daily
basis for weeks on end or months or even
years that people are making decisions
not based on but why do you think that
okay tell me okay let me give you why
you shouldn't be thinking that way or
why you think I shouldn't be thinking
this way without access to them at that
level it looks like it's not a model
it's just a conclusion no no look I
think you're mixing two things a I
disagree with you that almost everybody
is reachable I think almost everybody
starts outreachable but but in college
classrooms people were young enough that
it felt like a they were young enough B
because you were in my classes were so
oversubscribed and they tended to be
over subscribed because students who had
gotten a lot out of it told other
students who would get a lot the college
wasn't selective but our classes were
our classes were selected
um and uh you know I am I do believe
that we are all born in a condition
where we can
unless you're unless you're broken you
you can be reached early but then you
lose that capacity
um but there's no there's not a boundary
but it's it it's a slope right and so my
point is not hey everybody who did wrong
here can apologize and we could be back
to zero my point is the people who are
capable of delivering the necessary
apology can be made safe because the
whole point is it's the self-accounting
that allows you to deliver an apology
that doesn't have any you know gray
areas or you know places to hide uh some
kind of self-deception the full
accounting that says here's how I got it
this wrong is itself a demonstration
that the person has updated their model
either that or they have to be
diabolical and willing to say this and
not believe it and not care which is
very few people
I guess I think there's a third category
and I'm not sure
um I hope I'm wrong
but as I heard it you just described
an apology that involves a description
of the way of the ways that a person was
wrong
uh
inherently is either a company is an
update in the reliability of their
decision making in the future
or they're diabolical and they're
reporting something that doesn't
correspond to a change in the way that
they're going to behave in the future I
think unfortunately that there are a
whole lot of people
who in order to like I just want this
relationship back oh can we just do like
family thing family holidays again okay
you know what I thought about it I saw
you were wrong I mean
I fear that that's what people are
actually thinking but like I thought
about it I see that we were lied to and
I made the wrong decision and you know
here is why but here's why I won't do it
again and yeah I'm making like a
caricature of it I'm kind of rolling my
eyes but I feel like there's people who
can deliver an apparently good apology
who will be internally kind of like oh
that's a pro forma but I gotta get
through it because I really like this
person oh yeah I really like my sister I
really like my cousin I really like my
friend from high school I really like I
want I need it's my work buddy it's my
boss I gotta just do it and okay are we
good I'm really sorry okay good let's go
have a beer and I feel like there's a
lot of those people yeah and I'm worried
about them because I feel like they're
obviously from the past three years
hiding in plain sight well
I am not arguing that somebody who
delivers an apology necessarily deserves
a a clear cleaning of the Slate my point
is a proper apology that involves a
self-accounting that did not do the
following thing the accounting you are
afraid of and I also agree it uh
it is there to be feared is the
accounting that says what is the minimum
I have to acknowledge in order to get
past this yeah right the grudging
apology the minimal apology that thing
is strategic and it is it is functioning
to preserve the capacity to do similar
things in the future I want no part of
it even if that none of that is
conscious right whatever mechanism it is
that says I really I want to get past
this and you know you can hear people
who are actually good at apologizing you
will hear they are not monitoring
whether this is enough for you to let
them off the hook what they are trying
to do is tell you their own argument
with themselves here I'm angry at myself
here's what for yeah here's what it
looks like inside and I'm just going to
talk I'm going to let you see that and
then you're going to decide if that's if
that covers what you saw right and you
may say actually it doesn't I hear what
you what what you're doing there you
have found this seven things that you
did wrong but you've missed these other
two yeah like think on it some more and
then come back to me right yeah and
hopefull really we've all been there on
both sides like if we're adults past you
know the age of I don't even know what
but you know we presumably all of us
have
done done wrong unto others and had
wrongs done unto us that warranted
complex apologies and sometimes uh the
difficult conversation that happens does
involve it like exactly what you just
said
yeah you've got some of it but you don't
know all of it that's not enough
and go back go back think more come back
to me after you have and if they do yeah
right then what you have is somebody who
is now
hyper conscious of this Hazard that
exists in them that's the point is that
if you do this properly then you end up
conscious of things that most people are
not fully conscious of and so if you how
often does this even like you and I do
this with each other
we do yep and I think the audience
if you're watching
part of what you're watching for is
because you can tell that we do yep that
we are actually honest with one another
and it's not that
we're always perfect with one another at
all but we have we have both been on
both sides of that yep okay with each
other
have I been with other people I don't
know
like so we are lucky to have in our
lives each other with whom we can do
that with and with whom we do
I don't know that most people have
someone
with whom they can do that that it
wouldn't
just tear apart the fabric of the thing
and
it
disappears into the wind yeah I mean
I mean this goes to a different
conversation that we've had uh multiple
times here which is not so much here
this being the permanent temporary
permanent oh no permanent we have never
had this conversation here because this
is the first conversation we've had here
but in the past on Dark Horse we have
talked about the painful upgrade to
one's uh
friend group that occurs in crisis
because people disappoint you and
they're actually telling you something
that you need to know they're not up to
the challenge of being you know they can
be a friend under
simple conditions but if a friend who
cannot be a friend under difficult
conditions isn't really a friend and so
you lose those people and you gotta not
do everything to get them back because
if they're not capable of at least
apologizing for what they actually did
wrong then it's not really uh it's it's
not something to invest in but the other
thing is that people surprise you in the
other direction and you encounter these
folks who you didn't know before who are
up to that challenge and so I'm not
telling you that the world is going to
be full of people who are capable of
delivering a high quality apology and
deserve the Forgiveness that comes from
it but I'm telling you that that's the
thing you're on the lookout for yeah and
to the extent that you encounter people
who do that
um I think it makes total sense to put
them in a very different category than
you would put somebody
who has not made eye contact with where
they've been
yeah but yes yes I agree with you no but
I guess
no a butt which is that
one of the things I saw this week one of
the reasons I started thinking about
certainty was
I see
I see no
holes I see no tatters in the shield of
certainty that the people who have
accepted
pronouncements from on high since the
beginning of this thing have if anything
they're more entrenched than ever
well and they're more self-satisfied
than ever and they're more eager to
laugh at those of us who don't agree
with them than ever
so
yeah I want I want those people with
like with the with the real soul
searching and the real apologies
uh to to start coming forward but
you know it's it's like the entire world
is now politics
no I mean
everything is politicized by some Force
yeah
um but it doesn't own everyone and you
know you said something in your your
setup here
about the tendency if you were to look
at the group of people who's certain in
One Direction versus people who are
certain in the other direction it was an
evolutionary process in One Direction
and absolutely not in the other
um and this I think is key right the
fact if you haven't spent time if you
haven't decamped from your position and
seen the other side then you don't
really know how deeply you believe it
and in fact who is it Hume who
formalizes this principle maybe he uh
who cannot
articulate the other's position in those
little of his own or something like this
that sounds potentially humey I don't
know yeah uh it's definitely humorous
but um
yeah but anyway uh the point the point
is when you have an asymmetry like this
where one side gains
people over time right you've got two
sides that are claiming some something
is inevitable that's another prediction
then right there right so you know I
I said the level of certainty has
changed on one side and not on the other
and and the second prediction here that
you are making is one of the sides is
um gaining people on the other side the
prediction is is going to be losing them
yep so and we know they are because
people have actually gotten vaccine
injured for instance how many people do
you know who
um started out thinking these so-called
vaccines were dangerous and now think
they're safe right that's that's the
first yeah like it doesn't it's not a
known category for a reason and it's
because the evidence I mean there were
people like like the doctor I referred
to who was like don't do this like you
had to wait a little bit and I was like
okay
and that I'm now going to take it
okay well but then that goes to the
point that you and I were disagreeing on
which is the difference between safety
and harm
yep right that's right yeah so I would
let me use a different analogy than I've
used in the past you know uh is it safe
to get in your car drunk and drive home
no does that mean you're going to crash
nope you could get home absolutely
unscathed right so the point is harm and
safety are two different things we
understand the difference very easily
yeah and no and I and and you're right
that it's important like you to say that
you weren't harmed doesn't mean that it
was safe like this and I I feel like
that's a formulation that I immediately
grok and that I think almost everyone
would too you can say just because just
because I wasn't harmed doesn't mean it
was a safe thing to do whereas looking
at it on the prospective side is harder
to to distinguish between the two right
well people you know this is the the
problem of the bluntness of language
that comes from us all using a shared
glossary that we you know some of us use
things very precisely we're very
technical about it and we mean only what
it is that we intend to imbue into those
words and other people just sort of hear
it Loosely and so the idea of you know
is is that pharmaceutical safe right
well you know if you talk to me you're
talking to somebody who's spent an awful
lot of time thinking about how
Pharmaceuticals might be unsafe on the
basis that we have test animals that
don't tell you what it is that test
animals are supposed to tell you right
so you're getting a technical uh
response rather than a you know safety
harm what's the difference
[Music]
laughs
foreign